Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir sitzen hier vorm Salon in der Sonne.
Und fragen uns, was lesen wir als nächstes? Bevor wir aber diese Frage beantworten, hab ich eine Frage an dich. Was ist denn mit den jungen Leuten los? Wir haben gehört TikTok macht sie alle rechts. Das war die Debatte. Es gibt etwa 1000 Essays dazu. Jetzt gibt es die Tagesschau, die eine U18-Bundestagswahl veranstaltet hat bzw. eine Umfrage gemacht hat unter jungen Menschen. Und das Gesamtergebnis lautet Platz eins, die Linke mit 20,8 Prozent, dann die SPD mit 17,9, dann die CDU und dann erst als viertes die AfD. Ist also TikTok doch gar nicht so gefährlich?
Doch TikTok ist gefährlich, aber die Chinesen haben gerade andere Probleme als eine deutsche Bundestagswahl.
Komm, komm, komm, komm. Also ich will, ich weiß ja um Einflussnamen und so was. Und ich weiß ja auch um Trollarmeen und so etwas. Ja, und das gibt es ja auch. Und es wird ja auch hin und wieder dann ganz konkret nachgewiesen, was gemacht wird. Aber ich glaube, diese Debatten, die so unglaublich darauf abziehen, dass also von fremden Mächten unsere Meinung gesteuert wird. Wenn ich mir jetzt so ansehe, welche Clips nur der Koch uns hervorholt aus diesen ganzen Debatten, Bürger befragen, Politiker et cetera und wenn ich dann noch die anderen Clips wahrnehme, die so von der rechten Bubble hochgespült werden, wenn da noch mal irgendjemand sitzt mit einem Deutschlandkragen und fragt, Habeck, wie kann das denn sein, dass der Mindestlohn so hoch ist und so weiter. Wenn ich mir also diese oft sehr große Ahnungslosigkeit bei Bürgern ansehe plus die Ahnungslosigkeit der Politiker dazu, dann würde ich sagen, da ist ja sehr viel selbst verpräziert. Und wir hatten als Sarah Wagenknecht mit dem BSW im November Rekordumfrageergebnis hatte, immer diesen Diskurs, ja das wird alles von Russland gesteuert. Ich frage mich gerade, was macht dann Russland derzeit? Also BSW ist noch nicht sicher, ob die überhaupt in den Bundestag kommen, ob sie die Fünf-Prozent-Hürde schaffen. Da ist das ein Mangel an Kontinuität bei den Trollambien oder hat sich einfach die Meinung sehr geändert? Gibt es jetzt gerade ein anderes politisches Klima? Hat das vielleicht sehr viel damit zu tun, dass das Migrationsthema, das Wagenknecht lange bespielt hat, so sehr von März und Weidel eingesammelt wurde, dass man dafür kein BSW mehr braucht und das BSW versäumt hat, diese eigentlich linken Arbeiterklasse-Positionen irgendwie nach vorne zu spülen. Das heißt, wir haben es doch hier weniger mit einer fremden Einflussnahme zu tun und weniger mit diesen ganzen von außen manipulierten Faktoren, sondern sehr viel kommt doch einfach aus dem Inneren des Landes, aus der Wankelmütigkeit, aus Unwissen oder vielleicht auch aus Einsicht. Also dass vielleicht dann doch Leute denken, Moment, also Migrationsthema soll wirklich das Wichtigste sein. Also ich hab grad andere Sorgen.
Genau. Ich weiß auch nicht, was da los ist. Ich will eine Abos-Hepothese, die ich aus affirmativen Gründen meinen eigenen Gedanken gehen gegenüber. Also ich weiß nicht, ob sie stimmt. Vorher will ich aber noch ausräumen. Ich hab ja nie gesagt TikTok ist böse, weil China da irgendwas macht.
Ja.
TikTok ist böse, weil fünf Stunden Bildschirmzeit, die man mit nichts anderem verbringt als aha aha aha aha aha und man gibt jedem Video 0,3 Sekunden und danach ist das Gehirn tot.
Das seh ich auch so. Das seh ich also ganz genau so, dass das das große Problem ist, dass die Leute, die eine Stunde bei TikTok verbringen, fast nicht mehr in der Lage sind, danach ein Buch zu lesen oder so.
Ja, das wir immer hören, es war bei Huawei auch schon, da kommt so Technik und die ist dann, also die Kritik an meiner, hinsichtlich Huawei war ja auch, wir haben eine Deindustrialisierung in Deutschland, wir geben die ganzen Schlüsseltechnologien ab und worüber diskutieren wir, ob China da noch was einbaut. So und das ist bei TikTok genau dasselbe. Wir dürfen uns nicht in die Irre führen lassen, nur weil Karim Jostka und wer auch immer irgendwie eine Diskussion führt zum Thema TikTok ist böse, nein TikTok ist böse, weil es funktioniert wie es funktioniert und nicht, weil China da wieder groß was unterstellen können. Das zweite ist, vielleicht ist es nur ein ganz kleiner Shift bei der Jugend, denn wir haben ja beim letzten Mal gesehen, die Erstwähler haben zur Hälfte oder zum Viertel Grün und zum Viertel FDP gewählt, damit war die Hälfte zu, durch, unterm Strich zähle ich. Und die einen haben gesagt, wieso ist meine Bitcoin-Wallet so klein? Ich muss mich doch hier selbst ermächtigen. Und die anderen haben gesagt, wieso geht das Klima kaputt? Ich möchte doch in 30 Jahren noch leben.
Ja.
So.
Wenn jetzt überwiegend die Linke gewählt wird unter diesen jungen Leuten, dann ist das ja immer noch eine unterm Strich zähle ich.
Ja, nur in einer solidarischen Angelegenheit, nämlich man verbindet sich mit den anderen, denen es ähnlich ergeht. Während jetzt das FDP-Angebot ja immer ist, versuche es alleine.
Genau.
Die FDP, wir kommen zum Monatsende darauf zurück, wurde von Michael Bröker ja wieder ganz wunderbar beschrieben in seinem Podcast heute Morgen. Wenn noch mal dargestellt wurde. Also die FDP hat immer einen festen Kern von 5% an Industriellen, die geschichtlich auch mal so ein bisschen ausblenden, was sonst noch passiert. Auf die kann man sich immer verlassen. Finde ich eine sehr gute Beschreibung. Und jetzt haben wir aber eine große Gruppe junger Leute, die einfach sagen, ne, unterm Strich zähl ich, aber das geht ja auch vernünftig. Wenn jeder vor sich selbst die Türe da kehrt und so weiter, dann ist er an alle gedacht. Also wenn jeder an sich selbst denkt, ist er an alle gedacht. Der Satz ist ja nicht komplett falsch.
Nee, das stimmt.
Er ist ja nur so halb falsch. Man darf nicht die falsche Schlüsse daraus ziehen. Aber in Sachen Lebensweisheit ist das gar nicht so verkehrt, sich erstmal um sich zu kümmern und dann um andere. Die Frage ist nur, was man mit den anderen macht, die sich nicht um sich selbst kümmern können. Räumen die dann aus dem Weg? Oder kriegen die sozusagen so einen solidarischen Schutzschirm? Und in deren Sicht haben wir es jetzt mit einer Bundestagswahl zu tun, die zum einen uns einfach die konservative Wende älterer Leute, und ich meine jetzt nicht hochaltriger Leute, die den Krieg noch erlebt haben, sondern deren Kindergeneration. Die drehen halt gerade völlig frei. Also die glauben ja, wenn Dunja Hayali ihnen sagte, Flüchtling ist das größte Problem, ok, dann muss ich genau so wählen. Und dann gibt es deren Enkelgeneration, die einfach sagt, ne, unterm Strich zähle ich. Ich will am Monatsende noch was übrig haben. Ich kann nicht alles meinem Mieter überwiesen, auch wenn das der beste Kumpel von meinem Onkel ist oder so.
Ja, und was ja auch interessant ist, dass das eine Bewegung ist oder könnte eine Bewegung werden jetzt mit der Linkspartei, weil ja es nicht nur die Spitzenkandidaten sind, die sehr gut auf TikTok performen, vor allem dann Heidi, aber auch Gizzi ist ja sehr präsent auf TikTok. Es geht ja auch wirklich um diesen Haustürwahlkampf und das war ein Foto von Ines Schwertner. Da zeigte sie, dass sie mit 400 Wahlhelfern Haustürwahlkampf am Wochenende gemacht hat. Denn das ist der Wahlkreis auch nicht nur von Ines Schwertner, sondern von Beatrice von Sturch. Und das heißt, sie haben da jetzt also wirklich den Versuch unternommen, diesen Rechtsdruck ganz konkret aufzuhalten, indem man mit den Leuten spricht und sie versucht davon abzubringen, von Sturch zu wählen. Und das ist alles sehr knapp, wir wissen noch nicht, wie das ausgeht. Aber dass also solche antifaschistische Arbeit geleistet wird mit allen Mühen, die das hat, das ist ja eigentlich das sehr Beeindruckende und zeigt ja auch, dass möglicherweise da mehr entsteht als einfach nur so eine Partei, die man mal wählen kann. Sondern wenn man da eine solche Basis schafft, dann hat man natürlich ein ganz anderes Fundament, von dem man dann ausgehen kann. Denn wir sehen ja jetzt gerade an diesen neuen Umfragen, dass es plötzlich jetzt nicht mehr AfD ist und auch nicht mehr die Grünen, die beliebteste Partei bei den jungen Leuten ist, dass das sehr schnell wechseln kann. Deswegen muss man natürlich jetzt auch versuchen, wenn man da als Partei dauerhaft sich Rückhalt von jungen Menschen verschaffen will, dass man diese auch wirklich in die Arbeit einbindet. Und da wirklich mehr passiert, als einfach nur du darfst einmal pro Wahl ein Kreuzchen abgeben und das war's dann.
Das wird ja in der Ansicht eine interessante Wahl. Ich hab's ja schon ein paar Mal so gesagt, der nächste Bundestag ist schon verloren. Wir freuen uns jetzt über 6% oder so Linke im Parlament. Was ja nicht daran ändert, dass wir eine 50 plus AfD-CDU-mehrheit Bundestag bekommen. Das heißt alles, was die Linken jetzt gerade mobilisieren an in Amerika sagt man immer so Plattformen, wir würden jetzt so sagen an Ideen, politischen Programmen, wie auch immer, Milliardäre abschaffen. Ja, ja, wir werden jetzt keine Bundestagswahl haben, bei der wir die Milliardäre abschaffen. Aber der Grund und die Anlässe, Milliardäre jetzt abzuschaffen, der wird die nächsten vier Jahre von Friedrich Merz erst richtig dargestellt. Und da finde ich es auch interessant in Amerika und da können wir langsam aufs Buch umschwenken. Politikwissenschaftler saßen immer in ihren Seminaren, sind dann in die Welt getreten, haben irgendwelche Berater hier oder in der Partei da oder in der Gewerkschaft dort gearbeitet und man fragte sich so ein bisschen, ist das nicht eigentlich ein Hobby? Also hättest du das nicht einfach so lesen können, muss man das studieren? Und jetzt stellen wir ja fest, ja, dieses politikwissenschaftliches Zeug und soll man echt noch mal ein Littüre-Seminar zu Machiavelli machen? Ja, ja, das ist jetzt politische Praxis. Also man wird jetzt richtig herausgefordert. Man sieht jetzt in Amerika, ich will jetzt großen Fokus, liebe Hörer, googelt einfach mal nach Eric Adams, also der Bürgermeister von New York City, wie es um den gerade steht, wie viele seiner und er hat acht stellvertretende Bürgermeister, wie viele von denen gerade zurückgetreten sind, die Hälfte, wie viele Staatsanwälte dort einfach gekündigt haben aus Protest über das, was gerade abläuft. Also das, was wir jetzt gerade erleben, ist noch mehr als das, was man in sehr extremen Lektüre-Seminalen in politikwissenschaftlichen Unterrichten gelernt hat, in Praxis, echte Praxis, echte Menschen, echte Schicksale, echte politische Programme und neuerdings echte Technologien.
Ja, deshalb lesen wir The Technological Republic, The Crisis of Technology and the West, geschrieben von Alexander C. Carp. Sag uns doch, wer ist Alex Carp?
Alex Carp ist ein Mann ohne Führerschein. Er ist auf TikTok berühmt dafür, dass er, also ein Video, da steigt er aus dem Auto und dann heißt es, zuerst war ich zu arm für den Führerschein, jetzt bin ich zu reich. Kein Problem, er wird rumgefahren, er wird hofiert, er ist Chef von Palantir. Palantir ist also dieses Unternehmen, mit dem Peter Thiel abseits seiner politischen Ambitionen und finanziellen Möglichkeiten noch echte strukturelle Realitäten schafft, indem er zum Beispiel der hessischen Polizei Angebote macht wie, ich hab hier so einen Datenfusionsreaktor, den verkaufe ich euch gern, der ist auch gar nicht so teuer, ihr müsst jedenfalls nicht in Geld bezahlen, uns reichen die Daten. Wir hatten früher diese Projekte auch von Google, als Google gesagt hat, wir wissen, das Internet ist langsam, wir können für euch die Daten aber transportieren, kostet einmal eine Kopie der Daten, die wir transportieren. So ist das hier auch so ein bisschen. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob wir bei Palantir auch in so einer Art Realität von Person of Interest, dieser Serie von Jonathan Nolan sind, wo ja New York einmal komplett überwacht wird, nachdem man 2001 festgestellt hat, Terror lässt sich offenbar nicht durch Human Intelligence bekämpfen, also brauchen wir jetzt eine Maschine, die an jede Kamera überwacht und an jedes Mikrofon angeschlossen ist und so weiter und so fort. Und das scheint so die Mission von Palantir zu sein. Und der Palantir-Chef hat kürzlich zuletzt ein Buch über Kunst und Kultur geschrieben, das hatten wir auch mal kurz erwähnt, aber dann sind wir nicht dazu gekommen, das zu lesen, ich hat es so ein bisschen auf der Liste. Jetzt, wenn er ein Technikbuch schreibt, müssen wir es auf jeden Fall lesen.
Wir müssen es auch deshalb lesen, weil er ja sich nicht ganz grün ist mit Peter Thiel. Also Alex Karp bezeichnet sich ja hin und wieder mal als Neomarxist, wenngleich ich da doch in Zweifel ziehen würde, dass er wirklich weiß, was Neomarxismus sein könnte. Aber interessant ist ja, dass er sich eigentlich zur progressiven Seite zählt, also nicht mit diesen Elon Musk dieser Welt in Verbindung gebracht werden will. Vor allem wirft er ja und das ist ja die These seines Buchs, dem Silicon Valley vor, dass es sich auf Social Media Plattformen, auf irgendwelche Werbemodelle, auf lustige Apps konzentriert hat, mit denen man Fotos teilen kann. Aber die eigentlich wichtigen Fragen nicht angeht. Und da geht es für ihn ganz klar um die geopolitische Ordnung. Er beschreibt, wie brillante Ingenieure im 20. Jahrhundert quasi Hand in Hand mit dem demokratischen Staat, also den USA, gearbeitet haben, um dann das Land nach vorne zu bringen und die geopolitische Stellung auszubauen. Das sei nun jetzt nicht mehr Sache des Silicon Valley, so seine These. Das Problem sei eben, dass man sich auf schnelles Geldverdienen konzentriert und nicht mehr so eine nationale Vision hat. Ich finde das ja gleich erschreckend, finde ja besser, wenn Sharing-Apps produziert werden. Die sind nicht so böse. Aber man sieht dann an Palantir schon, dass also da die Ausrichtung eine ist von nationaler Größe und von einer ganz anderen Betrachtungsweise von Technik. Und ich glaube, wenn ich jetzt so den Klappentext lese, das Buch erscheint ja erst am Donnerstag, dass das vielleicht doch deckungsgleicher ist mit dem, was gerade mit der Trump-Administration passiert, als uns lieb ist. Es wäre ja eigentlich beruhigend, wenn man um Trump herum jetzt nur Leute hätte, die irgendwelche Meme-Coins produzieren, irgendwelche bekloppten Apps produzieren, mit denen man vielleicht noch mal die Demokraten ärgern kann. Aber im Prinzip alles recht harmlos. Wenn es hier aber wirklich darum geht, eine nationale Tragweite wieder in den Mittelpunkt zu rücken, bei technischen Entwicklungen und plötzlich das Silicon Valley da einen Shift vornimmt, dann ist das eher alarmierend vielleicht. Wir werden jedenfalls lesen, was er meint und glaubt. Und glaube ich, kommen wir damit den Gedanken, die jetzt gerade virulent sind in den USA, sehr nahe. Ich überlege tatsächlich, ob ich mal für den nächsten Salon noch das Unabomber-Manifest mitbringe. Denn das wird ja tatsächlich von sehr vielen in der Trump-Administration rezipiert und gelobt. Es hat ungeheuer Konjunktur. Und es ist so viele Jahre her, dass ich es gelesen habe, dachte ich, ich lese es jetzt noch mal und bringe es dann mal im Salon mit. Denn es gibt ja mehrere Richtungen gerade bei Trump. Wir können vielleicht uns Trump vorstellen wie ein Container. Wir wissen, Trump symbolisiert für so viele Leute irgendetwas. Das Problem jetzt der Arbeiterklasse oder der auch Eingewanderten, frisch Eingewanderten, die auch Trump gewählt haben, ist ja, dass sie irgendetwas in ihn hinein projizieren, aber dann ja keinen direkten Zugang zu ihm haben, damit er wirklich für sie mal etwas umsetzt. Die anderen Leute aber, Leute wie Karp, Musk, Thiel, die haben ja den direkten Zugang zum Silicon, zum weißen Haus. Die sind ja in Washington. Wir sehen das ja jetzt auch, wie viele Silicon Valley Tech-Unternehmer sich nun in Washington mal gerade nach einer Wohnung umschauen, um eine direkte Nähe zur Regierung zu haben. Das heißt, die können direkt etwas in diesen Container, der Trump nun einmal ist, hineinfüllen und da eine Politik draus dann machen. Deswegen glaube ich, ist es nochmal ganz gut zu lesen, was sagt so jemand wie der Una-Bomber und wie könnte das dann einen JD. Vance geprägt haben, der ja offenbar dieses Manifest gut und eingehend studiert hat?
Also weil du jetzt meintest, Karp ist sich auch nicht ganz grün mit Peter Thiel und Donald Trump ist so eine Art Wessel, die man irgendwie, also so eine Art Raumschiff, das im Weltraum und dann kann man es irgendwie über Gravitationskräfte so in seine Richtung ziehen. Das ist auch angewandte Politikwissenschaft, denn einer der größten Begriffe ist ja Einfluss. Also nicht so sehr die Macht, also jemand kontrolliert jemanden, jemand hat jemand in der Tasche das Kompromat und so. Das ist so Putin-Style, da gehen wir nach Kompromat, bei Trump gehen wir nach Einfluss. Also wer ist so dieser Letzte im Raum, der eben noch einen Tipp gibt, bevor irgendwas und so weiter, bevor eine Rede hält. Und wir haben ja schon Texte im Salor gelesen, die JD Vans darstellen als Körperteil von Peter Thiel. Also das ist die erste Generation von damals Kongressabgeordneten oder Senatoren, die nicht einfach nur, ah ja, ich bin in der Einflusssphäre von, sondern ich bin ein Körperteil von Peter Thiel und jetzt rechter Hand von Donald Trump. Und Donald Trump ist aber nicht durch Gespräch beeinflussbar, sondern da muss eine Stimmung erzeugt werden. Sich nicht grün zu sein mit Peter Thiel ist eine interessante Formulierung, denn niemand ist sich so richtig grün mit Peter Thiel. Peter Thiel versteht auch niemand. Man hört ihn so zu und fragt sich so, was meint er jetzt wirklich? Dann haben wir diesen kurzen Moment mit David Grapper vor 10 Jahren, als dann mal so eine kurze Augenhöhe und Problemdefinition sich angleicht, aber der Lösung fällt schon wieder alles auseinander und die Welt wird hin und her gerissen. So, also niemand ist sich grün mit Peter Thiel, aber Peter Thiel zieht eben Leute mit und gilt als Vorreiter. Peter Thiel war jetzt nicht in der...
Auch jetzt ja gerade, ne? Also diese ganzen, die Teenager und Nerds, die jetzt gerade dort den Staat umbauen, die Elon Musk dahin gebracht haben, sind ja auch viele, sagen wir, Ziesöhne von Peter Thiel.
Genau, die kommen so aus diesem, ich hab da mal ein Praktikum gehabt und wurde da als So und So eingeschätzt und dann komm ich in so ein Team und dann arbeite ich 20 Stunden am Tag. Das ist ja so ein zölibatäres Verhältnis. Liebe nicht deine Freundin, liebe deine Firma und so und dann hängen die da alle rum und nach drei Jahren sind die auch erschöpft und werden dann aussortiert. Das ist so wie beim Investment Banking irgendwie, nur eben nicht mit Geld. So, also da geht es zur Sache und Peter Thiel ist in der Ansicht eine herausragende Figur, dass er eben derzeit nicht in diese sichtbare Polygarchie gehört. Also er sah es nicht mit in diesem Foto als Jeff Bezos und Mark Zuckerberg und Mark Zuckerberg guckte in Jeff Bezos Frau de Colté und dann tauchte auch irgendwo noch der Softbank-Chef auf. Nein, Peter Thiel saß schon 2016 mit auf diesen Fotos neben Trump. Er war damals der Einzige, der aus dem Silicon Valley sich Termine im Oval Office und natürlich lass ich mich hier fotografieren und zeige mich und so weiter und so fort. Also wir sind hier, wenn wir Peter Thiel folgen, sehr weit in einer Zukunft, von der ich jetzt sage, ich muss ein bisschen verhindert werden. Weshalb wir solche Lesangebote dann gerne annehmen. Ich will mal einen Clip spielen.
Und vergessen wir nicht, dass der Sohn von Matthias Döpfner ja auch bei Peter Thiel arbeitet.
Ja, also Matthias Döpfner ist sowieso eine Figur für sich. Da können wir einfach nur froh sein, dass er gerade nicht 40 und in der Mitte seines Lebens steht, sondern auch schon so ein bisschen wie Olaf Scholz fällt nicht groß auf, wenn er dann irgendwann nicht mehr diese große Rolle spielt, weil er ist ja auch alt und so. Ich will einen Clip spielen, der uns das alles, was wir jetzt schwermütig behandelt haben, wieder ein bisschen auf die amüsante Ebene runterholt. Der Podcast ist sehr zu empfehlen. Er heißt Knowledge Fight. Klingt fast wie Infowar und genau darum geht es auch. Wir hören in die 1009. Folge rein. Dieser Podcast besteht nur daraus, den Alex Jones Podcast zu hören und dem zu folgen. Und da wir ja wissen, wie das immer läuft, dass Donald Trump sagt, bla bla bla bla, Biden ist ein großer Verbrecher, die bereichern sich, die machen die Wirtschaft kaputt. Und dann stellen wir so fünf Jahre später fest, nee, du bist der Verbrecher, du hast die Wirtschaft kaputt gemacht, du hast dich bereichert. Also es gilt immer, es gibt dieses niederländische Sprichwort, das ich nicht kenne, aber was über den anderen sagt, es gilt für dich selbst und so. Also diese Offenbarung durch zu appellative Ansprache. Und wir hören jetzt in diesem Podcast, der Clip ist jetzt nicht so akkurat geschnitten wie sonst, wir hören sozusagen in den Live-Podcast und es kommt ein Ausschnitt von Alex Jones, in dem er kritisiert und davor Angst hat vor dem, was wir gerade betont haben, nur er sagt es halt den anderen gegenüber. Also sein Feindbild sehen ja die Globalist Democrats und so, die jetzt eine Techno-irgendwas-Regierung aufbauen wollen, was ja zu verhindern ist. Und wir denken uns, ja genau, das ist doch genau mit umgedrehten Vorzeichen. Und da das immer witzig ist, wir machen uns so aufwendige Gedanken, lesen Bücher, besprechen die dann stundenlang und so weiter. Auf der anderen Seite klingt das einfach so.
Und irgendwie ist er immer noch wütend darüber. Ja, es ist sehr verwendbar. Also Alex kommt zurück und das echte Show ist auf uns.
Es ist einfach irgendwie leer. Es fühlt sich einfach leer an.
Okay. Wir haben durch den Himmel durchgegangen, um den Präsidenten Trump zu wählen. Wir haben durch den Himmel durchgegangen, um den Neue Weltkrieg zu erheben, die Syndikate. Und all die Siegene und Wettbewerbe, die wir gewonnen haben, machen die letzte Siegene so viel schöner. Und das macht mich nur so viel stärker. Ich will es nur so stark machen, denn wir werden immer näher und näher zu den Globalisten, die unvergesslich knallt. Jetzt haben wir eine sehr wichtige Transmission für dich hier heute Abend.
Okay, los.
President Trump versteht, dass die Globalisten versucht haben ihn zu töten und haben einen öffentlichen Plan, den Westen zu zerstören, damit das ganze Welt unentwickelt und starviert ist, damit die Globalisten Technikraten ihre totalen und kompletten, absoluten hegemonischen Kontrolle und ihre Technologie aufsetzen und ihre Depopulation-Operationen ausbreiten.
Ja, ich glaube, es geht noch das Gespräch weiter. Also, die Globalisten kommen über die Demokraten, machen eine Technokratie zur Depopularisierung. Jetzt haben wir festgestellt, ne, da kommen nicht die Globalisten, sondern da kommen die Nationalisten. Nicht bei den Demokraten, sondern bei den Republikanern. Bauen einen Techno-Staat auf, um die Ausländer rauszuschicken. Ja. Also man kann jetzt Alex Jones hören die ganze Zeit. Ich empfehle diesen Podcast-Knowledge-Fight sehr, die machen sich da sehr drüber lustig. Also am Ende bleibt nichts übrig von dem Kram und man fragt sich ein bisschen, warum gucken die das die ganze Zeit? Also es ist ja, da kommen ja auch nicht neue Gedanken oder so. Es ist ja einfach nur immer wieder derselbe Scheiß, aber man wird so zu gehämmert. Und wir haben hier wie in Person of Interest am Ende so zwei Maschinerien, die sich gar nicht mehr in Realität begegnen. Also wir werden nicht echte Kämpfe geführt, sondern die eine Maschine virtualisiert, visualisiert, sich immer wie die andere grad agiert. Und dann geht man das erstmal so virtuell durch. Also man spielt so Maschine gegen ausgedachte Maschine innerhalb der einen Maschine und trifft sich gar nicht in der echten Welt. Und dieses Bild doppelt sich irgendwie mit dem, was wir in Realität sehen. Denn wir haben die eine Maschine und die andere Maschine und die spielen das über die Öffentlichkeit. Also die Demokraten und die Republikaner stehen sich gerade nicht, wie vor 200 Jahren so mit Sperr und Gewehr und so gegenüber und dann versucht man so viel wie möglich der anderen zu erschießen oder so, sondern nein, alle führen über die Medien so einen Unterstützungswahlkampf die ganze Zeit. Und man fragt sich, wo sind eigentlich die Demokraten? Und ich denke mir so ein bisschen, nein, jetzt bitte keine Demokraten zeigen. Amerika hat gewählt und jetzt muss auch Entzauberung mal stattfinden. Auch ein politikwissenschaftliches, nicht ganz, ein Grundbegriff und so, eine Theorie, aber wir haben doch häufiger gehört, nein, die AfD kann sich nicht entzaubern. Elon Musk hat gerade glaube ich sehr große Angst davor, dass man ihn entzaubern kann. Denn dieses Projekt, was er vorhat, wird nicht klappen. Diese Technokratie, die er da, egal mit welcher KI und egal mit welcher Datengrundlage, so wie er sich das vorstellt, wird es nicht funktionieren. Es klappt auf organisationaler Ebene nicht und erst recht nicht auf dieser gigantisch großen politischen Ebene so. Und eine Entzauberung muss dann auch mal stattfinden.
Aber auf der Ebene der Organisation dann vor allem, denn Twitter war ja im Prinzip eine Klitsche, die er umstrukturiert hat, verglichen mit den Vereinigten Staaten, die er jetzt umbauen will. Und was er dann als Gewinne vorweist oder als Erfolge vorweist, ist ja geradezu lachhaft, dass er dann irgendwelche Posten auflistet, die nun gestrichen werden. Und es handelt sich da zum Teil um Millionenbeträge, die eingekürzt werden. Man kann sich, wenn man sich mit den USA beschäftigt, überhaupt nie mit Millionen beschäftigen. Was soll da gespart werden? Das ist ja geradezu idiotisch. Aber das zeigt dann, dass er eigentlich diese Dimensionen gar nicht richtig begreift. Oder er begreift es schon und versucht vorzutäuschen, dass er gerade sehr viel ändert. Wir werden jedenfalls über dieses Buch sprechen. Noch ein Hinweis zur letzten regulären Folge, die wir hatten, in der wir Pokémon-Karten ausgepackt haben. Daraufhin hat mir ein Hörer Alexander geschrieben, dass Trump ja auch schon Sammelkarten 2022 von sich herausgegeben hat. Es gibt da auch ein sehr schönes Video wozu. Also das ist quasi unsere US-Politik jetzt gerade. Also die Sammelkarten sind auch Trump-Politik. So muss man es auch verstehen. Womit ich nicht gesagt haben will, dass die Leute die Sammelkarten horten in irgendeiner Weise was mit Donald Trump zu tun haben. Aber strukturell sehen wir eben jetzt gerade wie es nicht nur ein Shift gibt hinsichtlich der Technologie, sondern auch dass die popkulturellen Entwicklungen gerade alle im Weißen Haus auch stattfindet oder da noch in verstärkter Weise dann aufgegriffen werden.
Lass mich diesen Gedanken nochmal aufgreifen. Also wir haben, das ist nicht das erste Ball, das wir Karten in der Politik sehen. Ich erinnere mich, dass während des Irakkriegs nach 2001, also ab 2003, wurden die amerikanischen oder die Feinde des Westens auch auf Karten und dann wurde sogar Medial damit gespielt. Saddam Hussein und dann seine drei Handlanger und so weiter. Das wurde auch immer mit Karten visualisiert. Deshalb ich jetzt anders als du sagen möchte, wenn das losgeht, bin ich dabei im Kartenspiel. Pokémons werd ich nicht spielen.
Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie dieses Spiel dann aussieht. Es gibt ja schon sowas wie Diktatorenquartett oder sowas. Vielleicht kommt jetzt bald mehr an diese Richtung.
Ich meine, das Vision Board, also dieses unterm Strich zähl ich, das Vision Board. Ich möchte, was weiß ich, in einem Jahr nach New York, damit ich nicht wie Udo Jörgens irgendwann zu spät feststelle und so, wie das Lied heißt. Man macht also so einen Schrank auf oder man setzt sich mit Freunden hin oder man hat das so am Spiel geklebt oder am Kühlschrank, wie auch immer. Das sind auch Karten. Also man visualisiert sich Sachen über Karten. Organisationsberater, riesige Tafeln, dann wird alles in Karten und so weiter. Das Problem sind nicht die Karten, das Problem ist Pokémon. Pokémon ist Inhaltslehrer Müll. Ich bin sehr für diese Art von Kartenspiel, aber dann bitte die richtigen Inhalte.
Und die anderen Inhalte, die stecken in Büchern, deswegen sprechen wir im Salon immer ausführlich darüber. Wer sich jetzt noch fragt, was ist der Salon? Der Salon sieht so aus, dass man hinter die Paywall treten muss, um ihn zu hören. Und dann erlebt man, wie wir etwa zwei Stunden lang über ein neues, relevantes Buch sprechen. Das ist diesmal das Buch von Alex Karp. Und anschließend geben dann Stefan und ich jeweils noch fünf Texte mit, die uns in dem vergangenen Monat fasziniert haben, die lesenswert sind, die diskursbereichernd sind. Und im Ganzen dauert das dann etwa drei, dreieinhalb Stunden. Das ist also der Zusatzinhalt zu den regulären neuen Zwanziger-Folgen, die es ja immer Ende des Monats gibt. Den Salon gibt es dann immer Anfang des neuen Monats. Etwa siebte, achte, neunte wird er in der Regel veröffentlicht. Wer jetzt sagt, da bin ich doch dabei, das will ich hören, kann das ganz einfach tun, indem man am besten ein Steady-Abo abschließt. Man geht auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de. Dort findet man einen goldenen Button und wird dann gleich zu Steady geführt und kann sich dann ein Abo-Modell aussuchen. Ab drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei und man bekommt dann auch alle vergangenen Folgen, die es überhaupt gibt, die wir je aufgenommen haben. Also von Januar 2020 an. Außerdem kann man uns auch über Patreon hören. Wer also dort schon angemeldet ist und uns lieber darüber buchen will, kann das auch so tun. Und jetzt sag du uns noch, wie ist das mit den Apple-Kunden, die Apple auf keinen Fall verlassen wollen?
Ja, wer ein iPhone hat, hat ja da die standardmäßige Podcast-App, Apple Podcast drauf. Wenn man da die neue Zwanziger sucht, macht es Apple einem besonders leicht, weil dann im regulären Feed einfach auch die Salonfolgen mit auftauchen. Was bedeutet, da ist man dann nur ein Klick davon, ein Tipp davon entfernt und kann direkt hören.
Wunderbar. Dann sehen wir uns erst mal Ende des Monats. Dann sprechen wir natürlich auch ein bisschen über die Bundestagswahl. Dann haben wir nämlich die Ergebnisse und dann im Salon alles Weitere zu Alex Karp.
Also viel Spaß bei der Wahl. Denkt an euch. Unterm Strich zählt ihr und dann den Kämpfer, den man für seine Anliegen braucht, seine echten Anliegen. Vorher nochmal klären, was sind die eigenen echten Anliegen und dann wählen gehen.
Bis dann.